i don't need to have that kind of
picture of your wife like that dad she's
your angel she's your queen
you said you love her you lift her you
lift her why are you digging around
diminishing her bum she's beautiful
[Music]
yeah man do you want to do them on the
[ __ ] yes let me find one
uh hey guys big fan of the pod found out
about the pod on tick tock in july
august last year and i haven't missed an
episode since thank you
much love to you man and keep doing your
thing my dilemma slash amma diazo
is that i've been dating my girl for a
few months i'm madly in love with her
and i'm very confident but i'm very
confident she's the one
but there's a small problem as
absolutely stunning as my girl is
she doesn't have much body it's one of
those ones where she looks better in
clothes than without clothes
but her face is i know but her face is
top tier
and her face is top tier and so is the
head and the sex is pretty good as well
but my ex had cheeks he put ease fam
cheeks galore and the sloppy top is also
top tier
the sex in all honesty was better with
my ex and she hits me up frequently
and she hits me up recently and
frequently to say she's down to be
a sighting just for the sex oh and she
won't air man out because she
she's got her own situation where her
new man is doing her new man isn't doing
bits
i said no immediately but i can't lie
the thought pops in my head once in a
while
what do you think i should do do you
need a summary
are you good oh i'm good what does that
remind me of um um
but my phone be blowing up temptations
on my line
i stare at the screen a while before a
first decline
oh
i'm stronger enough to face it and i'm
trying
oh what are you doing um i'm just giving
a summary for the for the fandom for
these lots
so he's got a girl he says he's madly in
love with the um
she thinks she's the one um she's
banging in the face
but she's she's a slim thing apparently
her body is not doing too much for him
and he says that she feels that he said
that he thinks she looks better
with clothes than without clothes that's
cold old cars
that is mad that's cold bro um that's
very cold that's your girl you know that
you're mad in love with sweat on
uh say well
anyway um his ex is hurrying up his ex
has mad cheeks and the sloppy top is a1
um she's got a current ting as well so
they
she knows that she's not gonna air him
out and he's not gonna air her out and
what should he do
cool before i dive into this one just
from the last few episodes alone
it's proven to me that
when i can hear that i can um
when females aren't getting delicious
pipe
they're willing to do whatever whatever
it takes and they're not even gonna
they won't even go looking for new pipe
that might be good
they know what's good and they're going
to go back to it that's the thing women
tend to always go for old dick when
they've got a [ __ ] dick currently
they like to stick with what they know
exactly because they don't the thing is
they don't want to
increase their numbers that's what they
don't want to do yeah they don't want to
use them
and if it's a good recycler [ __ ] as
well that's such
[ __ ] if you've broken up with a guy
and then he's got a new girlfriend
you've got a new boyfriend and you got a
new body count and the dick's not good
so you're getting new dick but it just
technically happens to be that you've
had before i don't give a [ __ ]
add that to your body count your slack
add it to your body count you don't get
that
you don't you don't get to turn around
and say i've only fought three guys
you [ __ ] seven how dare you you're
willing to homewreck
if you're willing to cheat and have
someone else cheat yeah it's a new body
i don't care what you say there's new
rules now new rules new rules now we've
said it you heard it
down to be a sighting because i've got
my mainers i've got my main aspect i'm
not gonna
fight i'm not gonna air it what a
predicament my mouth was water
fat i'm salivating as we speak my mouth
would water if i read that text i'll be
thinking oh [ __ ]
here we go what's testing me boy god is
testing me
i just found the love of my life i just
found the love of my life
it grows granted she's slim but i'm here
yeah um
how do i explain that one
she looks better in clothes that's harsh
my g
that's harsh like i can understand like
i'm not trying to bag you out
but like it goes your girl first then
asked do you know what i mean
protector of course that's protected
that makes sense hundred percent like i
can understand your fun and games yeah
it's all fun and games but that's your
wife yeah
come on now she didn't need to say that
yeah you didn't need to
need to dig that in and i could i get
this for context but you could have just
said she's a slim team yeah
you could have just said i i thought you
could have just said i find my ex more
physically attractive than my current
girlfriend
you're just yeah saying that she look
this is it's twisting the knife a little
bit you stabbed her already now
you stopped already without commenting
that's your wife cause like you uh you
look after her man
look after she's got no one else and you
said your mind in love
your family what's this this alphabet's
doing this to me
xavier omar fam man said if this is love
i don't want it
i don't need it i can live without it
that's tough
fam it that's not on but anyway
uh i can understand that is a
very very tempting endeavor
um what did he say am i the [ __ ] for
because he doesn't oh as far as i'm
aware okay no no no it's not he said uh
dilemma i was like i think the am i the
awesome maybe
future tense because you know he says
he knows regardless of what you might
say
once i've done it am i the answer
i never slash everybody else okay well
later well played
um but yeah like uh
yeah [ __ ] bro when you do it yeah of
course you're the [ __ ]
i'm never going to say being a cheap
mates you not an [ __ ]
uh digging unfortunately yeah
bro you you i know you didn't mean any
harm
but this that little statement you made
about your girl's physique
that was a bit of an [ __ ] this is a
shoot not a bit yeah
yeah that is i'm gonna say it because i
know he i can tell by the message he
didn't mean to be malicious i know but
it's just it's not for us yeah that i i
don't need to have that kind of picture
of your wife like that dad
she's your angel she's your queen you
said you love her you lift her you
lift her why are you digging around
diminishing her mum
she's beautiful um but yeah like i
understand
it's scary i don't know i just feel like
maybe i've lived a a certain type of
life
but i don't really some of some of these
type of ones when it comes to just like
when the mix comes between um
sexual gratification
and relationship status mix when those
lines get blurred
it's always confusing for me because
i've never
i've never really been in that scenario
where i've been like
i want to be with this girl
but [ __ ] her isn't
making me happy i don't know like i
guess
and again i've treated young girls in
the past but it's never been like
you didn't cheat because i didn't i
didn't cheat because i wasn't having
good sex at home
i just cheated because i was a man and i
was an [ __ ] and i'm wanting to do it
but um it's tough for me
because i've never yet i've never been
in a situation personally
where i've been like i love this woman
especially the women say it a lot like i
really like this guy but they did gave
me [ __ ]
so i'm gonna have to lock it i've never
been in that situation where i've
just been like why is it that bad is it
that bad
that you're gonna lock it that's people
go through
stuff that's stuff i don't want to go
through
fact i have to lock it how bad is bad
because
especially from from my i was so for a
guy problem is not putting
palm is not poem yeah but to an extent
yeah as long as i'm not because
obviously the women they're not nutting
yeah
so this is torment for them yeah yeah
then or not and i can understand that
this is just this is just unacceptable
yeah i haven't come in weeks yeah i mean
i can understand what they're going back
to x and say look i'll be your side ting
i'll be your scum i'll do whatever piss
on me fam just make me come yeah
i can understand what i go through that
and i can understand why the x is
hitting you up yeah
um but uh yeah for the man's
i'm just like as long as you're not in
is it worth i don't i don't understand
that
why are you he why are you contemplating
breaking up with this girl
he doesn't want to break up with her i
just want to cheat he wants to cheat
because he's not sexually attracted to
he's not hit the appearance of his girl
naked doesn't do it for him as much as
his ex
because his ex has cheeks galore and the
sloppy toppings i think that's the thing
is
actually that's that's the point of me
as well i've never a wife to go
who i if i looked and said you look
better in closing without
you wouldn't make it to my wife exactly
that was his mistake in the first time
yeah yeah okay cool yeah yeah yeah
that's
that's ed out a bit better for me yeah
you're done [ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
it's your fault from you you've got
yourself in this dilemma there yeah
yeah because your wife the girl who you
want physically attracted you you
found the personality you found the
person that you thought i'm going to
have to watch in the face you said the
faces you fed the faces banging you
found the personality
the wife has to be everything for you
she might not be everything for everyone
but she needs to be everyone everything
for you and when she's not everything
you end up messaging the podcast saying
[ __ ] about her that ain't cool
it wasn't cause that wasn't cool man ah
man said am i the answer because he
knows he's gonna do it oh family he
hasn't done it he said i'm on the
[ __ ] because i'm doing it he's
probably already done it because this is
probably i'm looking to clap those
cheeks
in about 25 25 minutes hurry up and
reply yeah
reply or don't because i'm doing it
it's a delight it's a dilemma am i also
dependent on when i get your feedback
gang we just he's from canada oh he's
from canada put that in a separate
message yeah
um ah broski i'm sorry man
you are the [ __ ] it's not dilemma
anymore i know what you did because you
you've already
know what you do we know you've clapped
our cheeks yeah um
yeah you you [ __ ] up when you wife the
girl who you weren't physically
attracted to
and that is is a lesson learned gee
because if you think
if he thinks he's just gonna bust this
nut yeah in his mis in his ex
and then everything's going to be
hunky-dory it's not you're going to keep
going back keep going back keep going
back
even though the fact that you said uh
your ex has a man so she's not even
trying to
be with you kind of thing if your ex
is still trying to [ __ ] you then clearly
she's having issues in her relationship
yeah exactly so it's probably going to
end up at a point where
oh should we just get back together kind
of thing yeah yeah it's going to get
mixed up
and even if it's a case of like edison
things well even what happens is like
she's like you know what i don't want to
do this anymore
i want to be faithful so she locked you
off what are you just going to go back
to the
wife you don't like [ __ ] he's just
going to find someone else she's going
to find someone else and the next one
the next one next one and then like
who's [ __ ] your wife in these times
ah it's it's long man
she's not going to wait around to get
piped you shouldn't have wi-fi if you
knew that
she wasn't appealing to you physically
yeah like
body shape-wise you just said just like
you like getting ahead of her and that's
about it
but you can get head off any girl you
know i mean anyone with a mouth can give
you slopped you know i mean it's you
didn't yeah you didn't have to wife her
just for that
yeah she might her personality might
have been great she might be physically
um
she might be beautiful in the face but
if the body isn't doing it for you then
why did you make her
yeah you're gonna have to break up with
her g sorry we're gonna we're gonna jump
three steps ahead
you're gonna have to dump your
girlfriend there's no other what's best
for her because you're not physically
attracted to her
it is what's best for her and it's
what's best for you obviously it doesn't
make any sense you're gonna force
yourself to [ __ ] her until you can't
force yourself anymore
but yeah that's when you get yourself
into some army hammer [ __ ]
anything to get it up
anything to get up anything you're
willing to cut this [ __ ] to get hard so
yeah enjoy that one my g i hope the knot
was worth it you can't
take it cause we already know you [ __ ]
up yeah you already did it you already
did it you're ready
we're wrapping it up here you did it you
did it just owner you are the awesome